godzilla has had his fair share of
appearances in anime and animated shows
as godzilla earth he appeared in three
anime flicks of his own storyline
well this year 2020 godzilla came up as
a cameo in an anime movie called
shinkansen henke robo shinkali on the
movie the marvelous
fast alpha x that comes from the future
yeah they should really think about
cutting short the name of the movie to a
few words
so in this movie he was seen as a giant
kaiju not differing much from his usual
form
but unique in many aspects as well in
this show he was codenamed snow godzilla
and he comes from another dimension
playing the role of an unstoppable force
that manifests at random
anyway before we go on to describing the
g-man
we need to ask first what in the world
is shinkansen henke robo shinkalion
well after reading quite a lot and
seeing their show it is one of those
usual japanese robo mecca
anime with transforming robots that are
piloted by humans inside them
something like the ancient ninja robot
shows so in this show
there is a secret organization and this
organization combats mysterious beings
with shenkalians
which are bullet trains that turn into
giant robots
so far to the extent of the franchise
there is only one season of the series
and one movie in which the g-man appears
in
so how come godzilla came as a cameo in
this anime and how does it connect to
toho
so also known as shinkansen deformation
robots in kalyan alpha x
yep still a long ass name it is a 2019
touhou anime film directed by
takahiro ike zoe but there have been
speculations as to toho stealing the
gemstone godzilla design since
snow godzilla looked exactly like him
well after much research we find that
gemstone was one of the first
prize winners for a contest held by toho
and snow godzilla in shinkalion
was a result of the collaboration
between them both
now going on to snow godzilla's design
as such just now he was an exact replica
or somewhat similar to gemstones
godzilla from a short
video titled g versus g which showed
godzilla fighting against dragon
the snow godzilla was an anime while
gemstone was
more of an elaborate cgi model anyways
no godzilla took many of the designs of
the past
he looked like a cross between legendary
shin and the heisei godzillas
the teeth and eyes resembled shin gojira
as they looked very menacing and evil
and the tail was super long and moved in
a prehensile manner like shin
but the most important feature is that
this godzilla is always covered in snow
and was white slash gray black in color
the dorsal plates took on the classic
designs of the pass
from shoah and heisei eras but gradually
glowed before an atomic breath like
legendaries
and the arms were very reminiscent of
the g-man from legendary
as they were more muscular and
well-defined the texture of the skin
however kind of resembled shin gojira
which was very irregular
and looks impenetrable by any form of
weaponry
this godzilla though having the build of
heisei series as well as the hind limbs
and feet
and he possesses another two of shin's
features which is the eye membrane that
protects the eyes
when he fires his atomic breath and his
overall height of 118.5 meters
or 389 feet tall okay
now for the powers of this g-man he
seems to possess the usual atomic breath
and just like every other iteration of
the kaiju the atomic breath also differs
vastly before he fires his iconic attack
the dorsal plates light up gradually
just like the legendary's g-man
but when the power reaches the mouth it
forms into a glowing concentrated ball
of radiation
and also during that time his eyes are
shut with another
shiny blackish membrane which looks like
shin's eyes before the atomic breath is
fired
a whirlpool-like phenomena appears
before his mouth which looks like it is
gathering energy from the outside
environment the breath is blue in color
with yellow spiral beams around it
making it look like the spiral heat ray
in the snowy version
another ability of snow godzilla is to
seemingly appear out of nowhere
and also disappear in much of the same
manner it was stated that this godzilla
is made up of glowing light particles of
the valhalla civilization
which was originally from earth millions
of years ago in the past
these particles have the ability to
teleport things through different times
and spaces
which is why godzilla appears only when
a vortex of these particles
form in the sky above also every time he
manifests himself
in the ground a blizzard of snow and ice
encompasses his body making it hard for
people to look at him or approach him
so in comparison with other godzilla's
over the years
this anime snow godzilla retains most of
the concept of the g-man but
the strangest thing would be his
molecular makeup being
that of glowing light particles his
height of 118.5 meters
is the same as shin and therefore making
him the third tallest godzilla of the
godzilla earth
and the monster vs titanus gojira he
attains the traits of being super
durable even against the shinkalians
weapons and special sword so all in all
we would say that this was a very pretty
good cameo
and would love to see it fight other
mecca's stronger makers in the future as
he easily overpowered the shingalians
and the main antagonist valdor which was
dubbed as a machine god of light
the ultimate planetary conquering force
of the valhallas in the movie
anyway the future of godzilla in anime
is being set slowly and gradually even
though the three
planet of the monster's versions did a
very average to mediocre work in
introducing the g-man into the
genre so that's all we have on snow
godzilla so make sure to subscribe for
more godzilla videos
and we do have a ton of them if you
haven't seen them all check them out and
smash that notification bell for regular
updates